[Music]
marie in des moines des moines iowa
what's up marie
hi dr john how are you remarkable how
are you
i'm well thank you good what's up
well
i have a brother-in-law who is currently
serving time for wire fraud oh good yes
oh good
yeah yeah
you sound thrilled marie congratulations
yes i'm really tickled about it it's
great um
in reality i'm really really mad you
should be you should be pissed off
yes yeah and
my sister so his
wife has now finally hit that point
where she's not in you know
complete chaos of
i don't know when the next shoe is going
to drop yep so she is finally mad and i
am just trying
to figure out how i be supportive of her
but also
not just bash her husband because i know
the time comes when he gets out that
he's still a part of our family
and i still love him even though he made
a huge mistake but i'm really angry i
don't know how to support her
and forgive him and rebuild
relationships when that comes oh you're
awesome
you're awesome she's lucky to have you
as her sister all right so are you ready
for this
what's that that's like a song y'all
ready for this
um
i'm not gonna do cartwheels across a
basketball court but
um here's a couple of key things and
you're already there just want to
reiterate them
never ever ever talk bad about him in
front of her
her story is about her
right and so
your story will be about you and you'll
need to go other places for that than
from her
what you don't want to do is have a
commiseration event we all just sit
together and talk about how crappy this
guy is how he screwed up everything
you need to love her and her grief and
her pain
and then you need to have your grief
somewhere else
okay okay
and
your grief is less at him you're rage
pissed off at him and you should be
idiot he screwed up everything broke the
law
but more so
this is really inconvenient
this blew up a picture of a good family
we had a we had a deal about how
christmas was gonna go and this idiot
screwed it up
and now y'all are left picking up the
pieces right
yes yes so i want you to grieve
the lost picture more than i want you to
sit around being pissed off at him
because you sitting around being pissed
off at him is just poisoning yourself
hoping he gets more in jail and he won't
he's already in jail
that ship sailed
every moment you waste being angry at
him it's just a moment i'm you're kind
of choosing to live a little bit shorter
life
because your body stress chemicals are
dealing with you not him
right
and then grieving the picture is
like man we thought i was gonna look
like this and it's not all grief is is
the gap between what i hoped for and
what i thought was gonna happen and what
reality is
and that's where you're sitting
now it for you
and
right
it's heartbreaking
but we often take our rage and we
wallpaper over our grief with it
and then we just die young or we get
addicted to crap
oh no thanks yeah exactly so just go sit
in the grief
and that might be writing a letter to
him that you're never gonna send him
that might be
writing a letter to dear christmas
here's how you are gonna look and i know
that sounds so lame but there's
something
physiological about it and hyper
psychologically cathartic about it
writing a letter to christmas dear
christmas you were gonna look like this
we were gonna have a tree
and tom and rick were gonna be sitting
around and there are gonna be kids
everywhere and it's gonna smell like
this
and now we're not
and there's a here's what we're doing
and this sounds bananas i know you are
linking
for i'm gonna simplify neurology here
neuroscience you're linking your
amygdala to your frontal lobe
you're letting that part of your brain
that is spinning out trying to solve for
chaos know
that your brain is back in control of
things
and it will go ah cool
what's next
and then you can decide all right what
is christmas going to look like now
and then it becomes
a a how are we going to plan it and then
when christmas shows up you're going to
be sad
i mean and i'm just using christmas
right this will be every birthday this
will be every family get together this
will be your sunday luncheons whatever
it looks like you'll be sad because
there's an empty seat over there
and that stinks
and it's okay to be how do i just listen
to like i don't even know what to say to
my sister or to her kids when it comes
up like i just kind of sit there like a
lump on a log because i don't know what
to say so one of the greatest things you
can offer somebody else in their grief
is your presence not your words
okay just showing up is important
and when they say things like i can't
believe my daddy did this he embarrassed
me whatever the conversation is your
response is i'm so sorry you're hurting
i'm so sorry that your heart's broken
nothing to do with him forget that guy
he's done his damage his appeal to the
end of his sentence
it's about their hurt in the present
okay
and
if they invite you in to solutions
then you offer
well what if we do christmas then you
start talking about solutions but let
them invite you in and it takes the
pressure off of you you don't have to
perform you just got to show up and be
with
and bring tacos
[Laughter]
bring food and
just sit
there's a lot of grief that happens
underneath a blanket next to your sister
watching the office for the 40th time
eating chips and salsa
terrible dietary choice not good for you
but we're just we're in this together or
we're gonna go for a walk
we're just gonna go for a walk around
the neighborhood
and okay here's here's a good boundary
if she's ranting and raving about her
husband
there does come a moment when you say
you get five five minutes and then we're
not talking about him anymore
and you will get to model for her what a
boundary can look like in this situation
and it will be a gift to her
because right now everything in her life
is consumed with this guy this guy this
guy this guy this guy and which because
he's a threat her brain is searching for
threats he's a bear and her her brain is
trying to solve for the bear
and what you can do by saying all right
you get five minutes and then we're
gonna go for a walk five minutes and
then we're gonna sit down and map out
what thanksgiving's gonna look like
she gets to go ah bear and then
back to problem solving
okay it's and now
what and most of us get stuck in the and
now what and we try to go back and edit
sentences that have already been written
in our lives and the world is begging us
to write something like
what are you right next what's gonna
happen next
right well yeah i just the past three
years of it has just seemed like we just
keep waiting for yes the next worst
thing so the shoe dropped wham-o
yeah
and just given the nature of my job
there's always another shoe right
but always always another shoe but
um you can't i mean you can't live like
that
no so i'll give you a um a piece of
advice that my buddy todd gave me
um he's a finance guy you may have heard
me say this on the show i mean
i get set off from
fiscal trump like it's all coming down
we're going to be trading cigarettes and
coffee and soil you know that kind of
stuff
and one day he's a finance guy he works
for the
he he's brilliant and i was just
peppering him with questions what about
this and then what about that what about
that and then if this happens then
that's gonna happen and they're gonna
call this and
and here's what he told me and i loved
it and i use it all the time now
he said john i don't have a meteorite
plan
if we're just driving along and a
meteorite hits us i'm going to deal with
that when it happens
and that one sentence has rattled
i don't have a
what if an army rolls on my driveway
i'll solve that problem when it happens
because it's not gonna happen and if it
does
and i know there's people like no bro
you gotta be prepared to get okay cool
great
now i've got lots of deep freezers and i
got meat for a year i'm still a prepper
a little bit
but
like i don't have a meteorite plan so if
the mob shows up in six months
the mob shows up in six months
let's plan thanksgiving
let's start exercising let's you and
your sister start a yoga class and just
start going
let you have weekly
ice cream with the kids we don't talk
about dad we talk about school and girls
and boys and gross stuff and ew you
kissed somebody like we're gonna go
there
just a weekly breakfast with aunt marie
whatever
or sunday lunch at marie's house
you get four minutes to talk about
husband and then then ah no more we're
not talking about that we're gonna talk
about today we're talking about tomorrow
we're gonna talk about thanksgiving
we're gonna talk about christmas we're
gonna talk about your birthday whatever
summer vacation
and then if a meteorite hits we will
deal with the meteorite then if another
shoe comes flying through this this
house great we'll do it then
and i love love love your heart marie
it's so great gosh your sister's so
lucky to have you awesome awesome
you're making my my
heart about humanity feel better
one person at a time marie
don't need to say the right things just
show up with tacos and a half bottle of
wine or something
and just say
i hate that
so sorry
man what a gift